we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
in any time of day many people do call
in very very late in the day or early in
the day i guess depending on what time
you go to bed let's take a listen to
this voicemail that came in David have
you heard about this study with your
group on out there studying wine and big
and they found that all the wine where
there's organic or not has roundup and
all the various roundup to it mister
tell you by the way
roundup it spread all over the world
finishing everything to eat and
everything for drink so you know I
missed and another little service what
you need to be restored on the street
I know even twenty years and we'll
revolved about a parent car wash yeah so
roundup I don't have that much to say
about roundup but I've talked about this
before which is that the term natural is
not a regulated term but the term
organic is a regulated term and it has
sort of a specific meaning that's
attributed to it and associated with it
however there are those including former
producer Louis who believe that nothing
is really organic because of acid rain
that happens as a result of
industrialization on our planet as a
result of winds that blow pesticides and
other chemicals from non-organic to
organic agricultural zones the it's I
don't really I I do still believe that
organic has a specific meaning and value
that the term all-natural does not but
there's no question that the idea of
organic food as sort of existing in this
silo not affected by many of the things
that we've done to the planet is is
clearly not accurate and I'm not
familiar with this study about roundup
on organic food but I would not be even
remotely surprised if that's the case
and I'll look into it
I appreciate the call on today's bonus
show today
the accused parkland killer wants to
give his inheritance to victims says his
attorney why exercise alone may not be
the key to weight loss something I've
been talking about for a very very long
time interesting story and also John
Boehner the former Republican Speaker of
the House is now saying that his
thinking on cannabis has evolved in what
way has it evolved well we will talk
about that on today's bonus show two
ways to get access to the David Pakman
show bonus show one is as a david pakman
show member sign up in mere seconds at
david pakman.com slash membership if you
want a 40% discount feel free to use the
coupon code vote soon 18 all one word
all lowercase that'll save you 40% off
of a monthly membership off of a yearly
membership it will make the monthly
membership just three dollars and 60
cents a month you can also get access to
the bonus show by becoming a patron at
the $5 a month level you get bonus show
access that's patreon.com slash david
pakman show
terrific bonus show for you today we
will speak to you then